hello from the David Cross do you study
of your background I know that some
books influence of you during your time
days to send it science I am curious to
know which are such books which you
which influence with you to study
science
thank you
hi so you're right Brooks had an
enormous influence on me and still do
I'm a great reader I had the fortune as
a teenager to be moved by my parents for
some years to Israel where there was no
television at the time so very few
distractions and I read voraciously not
just Science and Mathematics but
everything and and that was great and
reading popular science books and books
about mathematics and astronomy and
physics books by I remember by George
gamma 1 2 3 infinity and books even by
Einstein his wonderful introduction to
physics and and by Eddington about
astronomy really turned me on to the
excitement of modern physics and
convinced me at a very early age that I
wanted to be a theoretical physicist and
and I think that's you know the greatest
introduction to human culture and to
science is is through the written word
nowadays of course teenagers children
have the access to the Internet and to
an incredible wealth of information the
only problem is it's rather hard to
distinguish between what is good and
what is bad and and to be guided in this
unbelievable wealth of data and
information but libraries are just as
good and it's a great way to learn about
the world and what one knows about the
world it certainly is what attracted me
to science